في موضوع اخر على الجيش الصيني بدات
تدريبات عسكريه لمده ثلاثه ايام في مضيق
تايوان وقال في بيانا ان المناورات تعد
تحذيرا جديا لمن وصفهم بالانفصاليين
التايوانيين بسبب ما وصفه بتباطؤهم او
تواطؤهم مع قوى خارجيه وذكرت التلفزيون
الرسميه الصيني ان تدريبات تركز على
القدره على السيطره على البحر والمجال
الجوي والاعلام وتطويق كامل
بدء المناورات عقب عوده رئيسه تايوان
من زياره للولايات المتحده التقت خلالها
الرئيسه مجلس النواب كيفن ماكارثي
وقد شوهدت سفينه العسكريه صينيه في المياه
القريبه من تايوان حول جزيره بينجتان التي
تقع على بعد حوالي 126 كم
من ناحيتها افادت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه
بتعقب 42 طائره عسكريه صينيه في محيط
تايوان صباح اليوم وقالت الوزراء له تم
رصده 29 مقاتله اخترقت خط المنتصف في مضيق
وردا على ذلك اوضحت الوزاره انها ارسل
طائرات وسفن حربيه واستخدمت منظومات
صواريخ ارضيه لمراقبه طائرات الجيش الصيني
الوزاره دانت الاعمال التي تقوم بها الصين
واتهمتها بزعزعه الامن والاستقرار وتعريض
المنطقه للخطر وفق تعبيرها
سياسيا استقبلت رئيسه تايوان
الامريكيين يقودهم مايكل ماكول رئيس لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب وعربت
رئيسه تايوان عن تطلعها الى تعزيز التعاون
الامني مع الولايات المتحده وقالت ان
بلادها تواجه ما وصفته بالتوسع
الاستبداديه الصيني بدوره قاره لماكول ان
زيارته تعبر عن الدعم القوي لتايوان
واتحدث عن تسليم شحنات سلاح لحكومه
اذا ما وضعنا هذه المناورات العسكريه التي
تجريها تايوان في الصين في مضيق تايوان او
في مضيق الصين
الى اي درجه كيف ننظر الى سياق هذه
المناورات واهميتها في سياق المناورات
الاخرى التي جرت في الايام الماضيه وضمن
سياق التصعيد الجاري
نعم سلمى عبد الصمد حقيقه هذه المناورات
التي تجريها الصين واعلنت عنها الدفاع
الصينيه اليوم تاتي ضمن سلسله من التصعيد
الصينيه عسكريا سابقه تصعيد سياسي بالامس
مكتب شؤون تايوان لدى بيجين كان قد اعلن
عن حزمه من العقوبات تشمل عددا من
المسؤولين والكيانات الامريكيه بالاضافه
الى مسؤولين التايوانيين من ابرزهم سفيره
تايوان لدى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
العقوبات
ستنص على حظر هؤلاء الافراد والكيانات من
الحصول على تاشيراتهم وافراد اسرهم من
الحصول على تاشيرات لزياره الصين او هونغ
كونغ او باكاو خلال السنوات المقبله
بالاضافه الى حظر التعامل بينهم وبين اي
مؤسسات او جهات رسميه صينيه خلال في
المستقبل هذه العقوبات او هذه الاجراءات
التي تتخذها الصين سواء على المستوى
السياسي او العسكري سلمى تاتي بعد
التهديدات من الجانب كان شديده اللهجه
اصدرت على اكثر من مستوى سواء من وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه او وزاره الدفاع الصينيه
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه حتى قبل ترتيب
زياره رئيسه
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وايضا
ترتيبات لقائها برئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي قبل مقارن اللهجه كانت الصعيديه
من الجانب الصيني زاره الخارجيه الصينيه
كانت قد استخدمت مصطلح التواطئ بين
الجانبين الامريكي والتايواني رات في هذا
اللقاء المرتب بين اداره بيض وايضا اداره
على انه محاوله لتسريع استلام لشحنات
الاسلحه المتفق عليها بين واشنطن منذ
العام الماضي وهنالك ايضا مصادر عسكريه
تايوانيه ربما تؤكد هذا حيث كانت قد اشارت
بالامس الى ان الرئيس التايوانيه من خلال
زيارتها هذه المره ولقائها بالمسؤولين
الامريكيين على راسهم مكارسي كانت قد
تحدثت عن ض متزايده في منطقه بحر جنوب
الصين ومخاوف تايوانيه من زياده مسامته
بالتنمر الصيني في المنطقه والنفوذ
العسكري السندي المتزايد حسب وصفه تاي
وكانت ايضا قد حاولت حتى الاداره
الامريكيه بحسب مصادر تايوانيه على تسريع
استلام شحنات صواريخ اف 16 الامريكيه خلال
الفتره القادمه بالاضافه الى استلام شحنات
من صواريخ هاركون الامريكيه بحيث تكون
جميعها متوفره لدى الجيش التايواني بحلول
عام 2019 لكن الاتفاقيه المبرمه بين اداره
بايدن منذ العام الماضي والتي تبلغ قيمتها
نحو 600 مليون دولار امريكي تنص على ان
هذه الدفعات ستكون بشحنات صغيره على مدى
سنوات المقبله الى حلول عام 2030 بالتالي
سلمى ربما نشات خلال الفتره القادمه
تصعيدا اكثر على المستوى العسكري من
الجانب الصيني كون الخارجيه الصينيه تقول
بانها قد حذرت كلا من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والتايوان
شكرا لك شيماء مراسلتنا من بيجين